uh so next we'll have miklos roxy from
princeton talking about graph matching
and the community recovery two topics
that are there is to my heart so let's
welcome
later
[Applause]
all the organizers um
okay so first of all it's very nice to
be giving a talk in person um
great and uh yeah so today i'll be
talking about joint work with my uh phd
student ani sridhar
and so i'll be talking about correlated
stochastic block models and in
particular graph matching and community
recovery
so there's a lot of a lot of terms in
the title uh many are most of w which uh
will be familiar to many of you but so
i'd like to spend the initial part of
the talk just um
explaining all these terms and and how
they all fit together
just so that we're on the same page
okay so let's start with uh and please
stop me at any time if you have any
questions so let's start with the
recovering communities and networks so
this is a very well studied problem uh
you know classical example is zachary's
karate club where there's zachary
studied connections between members of
the crowding club and then
during his study there was a split in
the community
and because of the fight between the
instructor and
the instructor and an administrator and
uh
zachary just based on the underlying
network structure he could predict the
split almost exactly between uh the
club
first now we have you know this problem
occurs in at a much larger scale in many
areas many domains of science
so these include social networks where
we're interested in finding tight-knit
communities among people um and also
biological networks such as protein
protein interaction networks where um we
want to find
so communities of proteins which
correspond to a functional line
okay so in order to understand uh
various algorithms and how they perform
a natural thing to do is to study
probabilistic generative models and the
canonical model for studying um
duty recovery or community detection is
the stochastic block model
this was first introduced by holland
alaska and linehart in 1983
and so here
every node has is given a random
community label
and then
any pairs
any pair of nodes is connected
independently with some probability that
only depends on the underlying community
labels
and so this has been very well studied
um for the past several decades in
particular in the past decade um driven
by um
predictions from coming from statistical
physics and then studied in many many
communities
so the basic questions here are suppose
we were given such a graph but without
any community labels can we recover the
communities and in what sense can we
recover them exactly
can we cover them maybe almost exactly
or partially or or just can we do
anything better than just uh random
guessing
and of course when we talk about
such a thing we're always talking about
just recovering the underlying partition
because we don't we won't be able to
recover
the specific words
so this i will focus on the perhaps the
simplest setting
just two balanced communities so we're
going to have n nodes
uh each node will have a plus or minus
label id uniformly at random
and
so given the community labels if two
nodes are in the same community they're
connected with probability p they're in
different communities they're connected
with probability q so this is the
stochastic block model with parameters n
p and q
okay so far so good so
now what i want to talk about is
well the fact that
in many settings we don't just have a
single network but we have many
correlated networks that contain
information that we might be interested
in for instance if you're interested in
social networks well you could study
facebook or you could study
linkedin
but these
of course both are about people and
various connections between people
and
these but these networks will be
correlated but they're also uh different
uh facebook is more about personal
connections
uh linkedin is more about professional
connections so if you could combine
uh and so synthesize the information
coming from the two networks
that can really help you in order to
better recover the communities
so this is just an example from
social networks but you know such a
questions
make sense in many other areas so for
instance if you're talking about protein
protein interaction networks if you can
um
use
if you have the protein protein
interaction network of several related
species
then that can help you in in various
comparative studies and various
comparative studies can allow you to
better understand
these underlying data
so just as a historical remark so this
perspective was already
present in the pioneering work of um
holland lasky and lineart when they
introduced the stochastic block model so
in their notion the stochastic block
model is not just
a single graph but it's really
a multi-graph so it's really m
networks
that could be
correlated
it's a really in their setting on each
edge you don't just have an edge but
really a binary vector
we'll see um various differences with
with that there
as well
next what i want to do is
introduce a very natural and
probabilistic generative model to
capture multiple correlated networks
and this will be what i'll call the
correlated stochastic block model
okay so the starting point
is just a stochastic block model
and
again two
balanced communities
and you can think of this as the parent
graph so you can think of this as really
all uh social connections whether they
are personal or professional or anything
else
and then what you can do is well you can
subsample
this parent graph g
to get uh so what by the way what i mean
by this is every edge is included with
some probability s think of s is say
a half
and non-edges remain non-edges so you
simply simply subsample this paragraph
to get g1
then you independently subsample this
graph
uh another
sub graph which i'll call g2 prime
and then the next step
is to we're going to
so up until now
so the node labels are inherited and so
are the community labels
but now i'm going to uniformly permute
the labels the node labels for the
second graph and this is how i get g2
so there are various ways you can
interpret this uh one thing one way is
to just
think of this as you're giving the given
the two unlabeled graphs so you have no
information about the node labels and
if you're thinking about social networks
you may think about them as being
anonymized
and that's a reason why you might not
know the node labels
okay
so there's going to be
a uniform random permutation of the
nodes node labels we'll call this pi
star
and
this pair g1 and g2 i'll call the
correlated stochastic block model with
parameters n p q and s
and
to the best of my knowledge this was
first studied by honorarian gargan
archipen 2016.
any questions about the model
okay
so
in this construction marginally both of
the two marginal graphs g1 and g2 are
stochastic block models just simply the
edge connection probabilities are
multiplied p and q are multiplied by the
sub-sampling probability s
but these corresponding edges are
correlated they're not independent
in the two bars
and just going back to the original work
of hall and alaska and lightheart so
if you look at
g1 and g2 prime so before the node label
permutation
so g1 the pair g1 and g2 prime
is a stochastic block model in their
formulation
and more specifically they call this a
pair dependent stochastic
okay so
main question i want to ask is
suppose we're given
two correlated networks
two correlated stochastic block models
g1 and
g2 when can we recover the communities
and in this work i'll be focusing on
exact recovery
so up to just a
flipping of the two of the labels
and in particular can we do so can we
exactly recover the communities and
regimes where it is impossible to do so
using just g1 just
one of the marginal graphs
okay
so
in order to understand this question
first let's just uh revisit
the all the known uh
results about exact recovery of
communities in in a single scholastic
block model
so
first of all in order to be able to
exactly recover communities you cannot
have isolated nodes so the relative
relevant regime to consider is the log
the is when the average degree is
logarithmic
so from here on out
p which is the edge connection
probability within a community will be a
times log n over n
and q
will be b times log n over n
show that um
essentially this is the threshold for
exact recovery um if
square root a minus squared b an
absolute value is uh greater than square
root of two then exact recovery is
possible
in fact in polynomial of time
and
if square root of a minus square root of
b is less than
square root of two an absolute value
then exact recovery is impossible
so let's not worry about the equality
case
here
and uh subsequently abby and sandon
figured out the threshold for general
stochastic block models
um and in the interest of time let me
just skip the integration behind that
for the rest of the talk what's
what simply this
threshold will be what is important
so okay so if we look at
g1 what can we do just we just have g1
well then exact community recovery is
possible
if and only if this quantity is greater
than square root of two over s
up something probability
okay
so now what can you do if you had if you
have both of the graphs well suppose you
also knew the underlying latent
permutation
for the for the node labels in the
second graph
well then what you can do
is you can
overlay the two graphs
then you have to take the union
with the with the correct matching so
then you get
a graph like this here you have edges
like the green edges which are in both
g1 and g2
they survived both sub-sampling
procedures then you have edges like the
yellow ones or orange ones which
survived in g1 but not in g2
and also
the purple ones which survived in g2 but
not in g1
altogether you still have a stochastic
block model
just with the somewhat different
parameters
somewhat better parameters than in the
marginal graphs
it's not quite the same parameters as in
paragraphs is in the paragraph because
you can have
an edge an edge can be deleted in both
of the
sub-sampling
procedures okay
so
in this case again we can just
use the the known results as a black box
and exact recovery is possible if and
only if
square root of a minus square root of b
is greater than well this quantity here
okay
so in particular
there's this region
in between
where if we would know the
underlying latent permutation
then exact community recovery is
possible
from the two graphs combined but it's
not possible from just the marginal
graph g1
so
this motivates the question well
can we figure out
what this underlying latent permutation
is
so here's the next main question which
is if we're given
these two graphs g1 and g2 which are
correlated stochastic block models
and when can we recover the latent
permutation pi star
and in particular
we're interested in recovering this
exactly
okay so i motivated this question
which is known as graph matching through
this community recovery
question but really this is of
significant independent interest and it
has been very well studied over the past
decade
so if you
consider
this model where p is equal to q
then the communities don't have any
meaning and then what you get is simply
the correlated error syringe model
which was introduced by peter sunny and
grossplaster
a decade ago
and since then especially in the past
five years there have been many many
works including by many people in the
audience here
studying
this graph matching problem
for the correlated editing model
i think there will be
several talks later
okay so at this point uh i've explained
everything in in the title of the talk
so
this is the model of correlated
stochastic block models
and uh the main questions i want to ask
are community recovery and graph
matching and in both cases i'm looking
at exact recovery
any questions
so let me discuss results
and again these are joint work uh with
ani sridhar
so our main result is to determine the
information theory
threshold for when exact matching is
possible
so
it goes as follows so
if
this condition holds so s squared
times a plus v over 2 is greater than
one
then exact
exact graph matching is possible
and in particular you can use the
following estimator
so if you just
take it the estimator then maximizes the
number of agreeing edges between g1 and
g2
this is a very natural estimator i'll
discuss why in a second so if you take
this estimator then this will
recover with probability tending
okay
so if you look at this estimator this is
the maximum a posteriori uh estimator
estimate for uh in the correlated edge
training model
it's not quite the map estimator in the
correlated spm model just because there
are various weights in the
model but it turns out that this
estimate also works all the way down to
the information
threshold
so
in the air destroying your case
uh kulina and kiawash first studied the
exact graph matching
problem for the in the correlated data
training model and so they derived
this result in the education setting
and recently wushu and you
studied
the dense regime for this problem
so what is this condition
well if you take
what's called the intersection graph so
from
if you take the correct matching of the
two graphs and keep only the edges that
were
kept in both of g1 and g2
so those were the green edges in the
previous graph where there were also
orange and purple edges
and so if you
look at this graph this is called the
intersection graph and this condition is
exactly
the condition
that this intersection graph is
connected with high probability
okay and uh so i mentioned that owner
and gargan arki first
studied the court this correlated
stochastic block model model
uh so
they obtained the
the same conclusion
under stronger parameter assumptions and
also they assumed that all community
labels were known in both
graphs and that's significantly
it makes the analysis significantly
easier and also
assuming that makes the downstream
application to community recovery um
any questions about the
word very stupid question if
uh this is par so degrees one over n
there will be you know order and
isolated vertices and how can you find
the permutation for those
so we're in the logarithmic degree
version so ah okay
yeah
yeah so
any other questions
okay uh so uh
it turns out that this is uh indeed the
information theoretic threshold so this
was shown in previous work by uh kulina
singhal
mithal
and um
yeah so this is exactly so if this
intersection graph is disconnected then
you cannot
exactly recover the graph matching and
effectively what you can do is well in
this case
if you look at the intersection graph
there will be many
isolated vertices
and
what you can so these vertices
being isolated in the intersection graph
means that they have non-overlapping
neighborhoods
in the two
graphs
and so effectively what you can do is
you can just permute them
within the two communities and any such
permutation will give you
something with which has the same kind
of posterior probability so and there
will be polynomially many isolated
vertices so you won't be able to figure
out why
that permutation
okay
so
now that we know
the
the information theoretic limits for
exact graph matching we can
look at what this implies for community
recovery
so
if
so under these two conditions
there is an estimator that
what i wrote here is just that exact
community recovery is possible with
probability going to
one and
what is the proof well under this first
condition we can recover the underlying
graph matching with high probability
and
then once we have that we just take the
union graph and run any community
recovery that works down to the
threshold
okay and
this is precisely the
the threshold for exact community
recovery for for the stress block model
with those parameters
and the second condition is necessary
because so
if the second condition fails
then exact community recovery is
impossible
this is simply because
i could even give you the this
underlying uh latent permutation
and then you could
take the union graph and you would still
not be able to recover the communities
exactly and it's just
right now
okay
so
we can also uh plot these
results these regimes so
there are three parameters here a b and
s so let's just say fix the sampling
probability s and here this is
a and b
so
let's take say this
picture here on the left so here the
green and the green region you can just
exactly recover the communities from g1
the first graph
in the red region even if you have both
graphs you cannot do anything you cannot
exactly recover the communities
in the cyan region
you can't recover just from g1 but you
can recover from the two graphs combined
and in this yellow region
well you cannot recover exactly from
just g1 and we don't know if it's
possible or not um from the two graphs
combined
yeah
and in fact so
i'll mention this at the end but i think
we think that the answer is actually
that
the truth is in between so
in part of this yellow region you can do
exact community recovery and part of in
part of it you can't
any other questions
yes
uh yeah so that this is uh
this estimator is not you know
competitionally efficient so that's
another uh very natural open question
and i think there might be some
further results about you know efficient
estimators later uh this week for at
least the their training set
you know yeah
marginal marginal likelihood because
that would give i mean to average out
the labels
because that one doesn't care about
whether it's sbm or not right only use
some marginal
uh we didn't try that
okay
okay so
you can plot this in in different ways
depending on which parameters
and you see similar kind of thoughts
and
okay so let me let me say a few words
about the proof
so about the the
graph matching
okay so this is uh the estimator that we
and so there's this underlying latent
permutation pi or pi star that we want
to recover and this induces a
permutation on vertex pairs which we
call the lifted permutation and we
denote these by
um
tau
so we really care about these lifted
permutations since those are what show
up in this
estimator maximizing this
alignment score
so the score is really the number of
green edges there
okay so
what we want to do is well we want to
say that well
the the true underlying latent
permutation latent permutation will give
rise to
the largest alignment score so we can
just subtract
for any uh
tau which is a lifted permutation
we can look at its alignment score
and subtract it from the the
ideal alignment score if all of these
quantities
are positive except for
so this quantity is going to be 0 for
the true
latent
permutation
and if it's positive for
every other permutation then our
estimator is correct
okay so what we want to do is understand
this quantity
so
and this can really be any
this permutation pi can be any
permutation so
we want to somehow characterize how it
differs from
the underlying latent permutation pi
star
uh one way to do this is to understand
you know how and how many
entries does it differ and here because
they're two communities it makes sense
to consider how many vertices vertices
are mismatched in the two communities
let's call those k1 and k2
so just heuristically
if
k1 and k2
are
large then it's going to be
much more unlikely that uh such a
permutation is going to be the one the
one that has a higher alliance for it
but on the other hand there are many
more such permutations
now what we care about are not really
vertex mismatches but really edge
mismatches
because that's what shows up in the
alignment score
and so m plus tau will be the number of
um
edge mismatches that are within a
community and then minus tau will be the
number of
edge mismatches
between communities
and
so it's it's not too hard to go from
vertex mismatches to edge mismatches in
fact there's you know a precise
commentary formula that you can just
write down uh but let's just assume
so in the following we'll just assume
that these communities are indeed
approximately balanced which they are
with higher probability
and so
suppose that k1 and k2 are small think
of them as constant you know then indeed
if you have
a node
well then
if it's mismatched
then
there will be roughly n over two
other nodes and every everybody here
roughly who
it will be in a mismatched vertex pair
so the number of
edge mismatches will be
something like this
and over 2 times k1 plus k2
and this the same will hold even
across communities
so this only holds if k1 and k2 are
relatively small in general you only
have this bound with
an extra factor of a half
okay so
ultimately what we want to show is that
under this condition there exists some
delta such that
the probability
that the estimator
has
k1 mismatches in the first community and
k2 mismatches in the second community is
bounded by
n to the minus delta times k1 plus k2
if we can show this then we can just sum
over k1 and k2 and indeed the error
probability will go to zero
so
how do we show this well
there's going to be
we're just going to do a union bound
over all possible
such uh lifted permutations
and this gives a factor of n to the k1
plus k2
and so then we have to
understand this individual probability
and it effectively boils down to
computing bounds on the probability
generating function
of
x tau
this quantity that is the difference
in the alignment
and
eventually what we show is that this is
bounded by this quantity here
and uh
okay so you can see here in this
question this expression
these m plus tau and m minus tau is
coming up
which
as we saw on the
previous slide
at least something like
so
something like this uh if
anyone and kit who are small
and
at least
this is a factor of
half in general
so
you should plug that in here
um
you can see
well the end the factor of n cancels out
and you have
k1 plus k2
which appears here as well
so
if you
forget this and and you look at this
bound here then you see the s squared
times a plus b over 2 occurring
okay
now
if you just look at the probability
generating function of x tau
then actually you will only get you
won't get down all the way to the
threshold you will only
you will you lose by a factor of two
and so you have to work a bit harder to
get down all the way to the threshold so
you have to look at this joint
generating function of s x
tau with uh these other quantities
which um
let me not get into
right now
let me just say that um okay so
you have to obtain this bound on the
probability generating function
so how does this work
well
you want to compare
tau to the original latent lifted
permutation tau star and it turns out
that if you look at
this composition of tau star embers and
tau
well you can decompose this according to
cycles
and
due to independence across the edges in
the original model you have independence
across cycles here
so you only have to do
you only have to bound
this quantity for a cycle
and um what was done previously is that
in the correlated edition model you
could
explicitly compute this generating
function
now in the correlated thoracic block
model that just
seems then not possible because the
what this uh probability generating
function
looks like
it will really depend on the community
labels throughout the cycle and not just
how many of each each community do you
have but really where
which nodes have which community
so instead what we do is we compute some
recursive bounds
for the step publication
any questions
omega and zeta required because
otherwise
[Music]
it's dominated by
cases where there's a lot of dispatchers
in a lot of communities
and it's really required to deal with
the large k1 and k2 case
because
we want
here
in general we only have this balance
and so
we want to boost that up
and that's what we can do
okay
let me turn to some open problems
so
one natural open question is what
happens in this yellow region
and
so here exact craft matching is not
possible
and
but it still might be the case that
exact community recovery is possible
and so as i mentioned we think that in
part of the region
you can do exact community recovery and
part of it you can't
um so
recall that in this regime
just from a single block model you can
do almost exact recovery
so really the challenge is to boost the
almost exact recovery to exact recovery
um
using the other graph
um
okay so let me not write down the
formula basically
you have
uh polynomially many
nodes that you
that you cannot exactly recover
also in the in this graph matching you
have
some polynomially many
nodes that you cannot match
so somehow these have to
yeah well the blue will be some it will
be some something
and then here it would be red
so there isn't like a
yeah yeah yeah
okay
yeah that's a very good question and in
fact you know you'd like to do that in
order to
uh
applications uh and in fact there's a
paper by um
where what they do is if you look at
the
k core
of the intersection graph
for appropriate k
then it turns out that those vertices
will actually be
perfectly
so so indeed this is something you would
like to do and that that's uh
this is the k4 to be possible
okay
uh so
the third algorithm for exact craft
matching
is uh well it's not efficient so one
important question is do there exist
efficient algorithms for graph matching
graph matching uh so i believe we'll
hear more about this uh later this week
but regardless of what the answer to
this is
even if it's not possible to do exact
matching efficiently it still might be
possible to you know not
use
this particular algorithm but to use
some kind of
relaxation
that is polynomial time to recover the
community's exactly
so
this is not clear
it's possible to do or not
i think it's a natural question
you can study these kind of questions in
general for
communities with general parameters
and both the graph matching questions
and
questions of community recovery
also so
today i talked about exactly exact
community recovery but you can go beyond
that
and uh
for instance one thing you might want to
ask is
what happens in the constant average
degree regime
so there you can imagine uh parameter
regimes where marginally both graphs
are below the question
threshold
but the their union is above the custom
version
so in particular it's impossible to do
community detection from just a single
graph g1
but
potentially it might be possible to do
community detection uh by combining the
two the information from the two graphs
and of course the challenge is that in
these regimes exact craft matching is
impossible
so you can't use this as a black box in
fact
probably you can only recover
the graph matching um in some kind of
partial
way is that enough
to boost
estimates to get
okay
so let me just summarize quickly what i
talked about so i talked about
this model of correlated stochastic
block models
and we determined the fundamental limits
of
exact graph matching
and using this we saw that exact
community recovery is possible in
regimes where it is not possible to do
so from just one of the graphs alone
and more generally i think that
correlated random graphs
are really geared and pose many exciting
challenges both statistically and
computationally
so
it's very much in the theme of this
workshop
and more broadly this semester here at
science
okay so we have the time for
this is questions a good enough question
to deserve the mic
so the uh
it was not obvious to me at first why
even if you can do the matching the best
thing to do is just look at the union of
the two graphs
part of me thought oh but doesn't it
tell you more if an edge occurred in
both crafts and it doesn't in this case
because
in both cases you you know it was in the
you know the previous graph the one that
got sub-sampled but you can imagine
fancier
probabilistic models
where
the sampling prop probability is itself
uh
different
whether the endpoints are inside or
outside the community
[Music]
and so in that case maybe
you don't want to just take the union
maybe the the
edges of the intersection graph are
a bit more powerful
that's perfect yeah okay
okay any other questions
yeah i actually do have a one quick
question about uh this conjecture so
yeah i'm quite interested
so like as you mentioned the difficulty
here is really how to boost from almost
exactly to exact recovery yes
so then i guess yeah like uh
um i mean in this okay so you probably
can only use so used so it is enough to
use
just to
get almost exact recovery for example
yeah right and then the purpose is like
how to align g2 to g1 so that you can
boost it up yeah yeah so for that and i
i know you cannot get the exact one for
matching yeah but i just want to hear a
little bit more like i mean in this case
you can also get almost a perfect
recovery of the right you're gonna get
almost exact recovery so indeed uh there
will only be like upon only many
emergencies that are online uh and in
particular you you can achieve this with
this uh k-core alignment that i
mentioned
and so then you also know that those are
correctly matched which is really useful
to
go between the two ground
almost exact uh
yeah so it seems like it's doable but um
but but i'm literally surprised you said
like there's a regime where you still
believe uh like uh right so
um
you still so
okay so indeed it's doable so it's
something we're working on
but
so
you're going to have
you're going to have to use
so you're going to have some
say in one of the graphs you're going to
have some
notes that are not correctly
these are not correctly recovered
so you take this over to the other graph
and um so then you you want to use some
majority uh votes
to boost
the labels up to
correctness
but
that's
it depends on how many of these nodes
you have
uh you know are the parameters of the
block model there
enough to boost that up
so
that will cause there being this
boundary within this
yeah thanks a lot for sharing ourselves
that's great
questions
okay so
no question let's thank the speaker
again
okay so that'll be all for this morning
and then we're gonna come back at 2 p.m
induction